está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo escucha no tengo
muy buenas tardes ahora sí hola qué tal qué tal la tercera bala bala vencida
muy buenas tardes a todos vamos a dar comienzo a la clase de hoy
donde dejamos la última
que voy a parar una cosa no puedo pararlo todo el mundo entiendo que me
oye como siempre así que vamos vamos al vivo estamos como siempre por el
discord no es que había un par de consultas por email si podéis se ve que
podáis ponerlas en el discord si no es algún tema lógicamente personal que
para algún tema de privacidad pues lógicamente no se quiere compartir pero
si no hay algún motivo pues es escape siempre es mejor pues porque así ya digo
las las ve todo el mundo no y se puede un poco aprovechar todo el mundo de la
de la duda que la mayoría de veces cuando decir todas pues tiene tiene valor
para más gente no bien teníamos dos consultas que yo tenga controladas en el
discord pendientes vale si hay alguna otra más bueno está de más lugar
anterior no esto ya era una cosa que había respondido el creo ya estaba no
si si si vale Rubén preguntaba sobre la pasada clase respecto a un filtro que yo
dije que aportaba y perdía muchos trades no estáis viendo ahí la pregunta bueno
concretamente decía que bajaba de 5.400 a 2100 trades y que yo comenté que el
filtro aportaba y pasaba de 0 95 a 1 0 5 a marrugar no te la respondí vale pues
ahora lo mire yo pensaba que sí yo pensaba que si ahora lo miro la mira al
kit está el kit está está ahí atento me gusta me gusta vale entonces dije que
el filtro aportaba y lo cual no parece demasiado decía él se cuestionaba si
aportaba a ver que el filtro aporte no quiere decir que sea válido para operar
de vuelos decir cuando digo que aporta todas estas pruebas que hacemos de filtro
y demás al final son
prácticamente siempre evaluaciones preliminares entonces decir que aporté no
que sea válido porque podría ser que a partir de ahí pues tuvieras que hacer
pruebas pruebas adicionales todo caso en este caso ejemplo que no recuerdo el
filtro concreto que eran y demás es cierto la mejora es pequeña para la
pérdida de trades aún así te siguen quedando muchos trades de 2100 sigue
siendo una mostra probablemente muy significativa pero sí que el filtro
aporta poco es cierto el filtro aporta poco vale no no diría que que aporta
mucho ya digo no recuerdo el caso el caso pero esa frase que comentas al
final es cierta y te la compro es decir si se reduce el número de trades a la
mitad
lo que quieres es una regla objetiva porque ya nos conocemos y lo entiendo no
entiendo porque es como debe ser pero a este nivel no la hay no hay una regla
tan objetiva para decir tanto número de trades nos aporta pero
el sentido común es bastante útil y tú lo tienes y es cierto lo que ya has
dicho es verdad es decir me pierde la mitad de tres y me mejora tampoco no
aporta mucho vale pero bueno habría que seguir investigando el hecho de que lo
que quiero dejar claro es que el hecho de que diga yo que aporta no quiere
decir que el sistema es operable vale decir al final para operar para operar
seguramente hacían falta otras otras cosas
que más ya os adelanto que la siguiente clase que por cierto tengo ponencia en
robot trader os invito os invito a asistir
hablaré de salidas y justamente la clase que viene pues aprovecharemos para
trabajar salidas más en profundidad con las seguro que con los sistemas que ya
hemos hecho ya veremos si con alguna otra cosa no pero seguro que con los
que ya hemos hecho es decir trabajaremos tanto el concepto de filtro el concepto
de salidas sobre todo salidas pero puede ser que en algún caso pues de
evento que hemos algún filtro y trataremos de ella y hacerlo en sentido
que podamos obtener algún código operable por decir ya o que digamos esto
esto es operable vale eso será el día que viene
pregunta en ríg que sí que es bastante bastante buena plantea que si tú por
ejemplo en ETF es tienes datos limitados pero tienes el futuro que sí que tiene
más si se puede usar el futuro para para backtestear datos del ETF si se
puede vale de hecho comentas el caso de nuestro caso con los futuros y los fds
y es cierto si se puede no es lo ideal bueno no sería mejor poderlo hacer en
el en el dato bltf pero como tú comentas si no hay datos lógicamente es mucho
mejor backtestear en el futuro que no backtestear esto dices que parece obvio
y lo es estás en lo cierto es es es así siempre va a ser mejor backtestear en un
activo que al final lógicamente está muy correlacionado y a lo mejor podrías en
algún caso pues hacer alguna adaptación del imagínate el valor del tic aspectos
que puedan tener si te lo permite el programa o te lo permite la uno puedes
construir datos ahí podías hacer cosas pero bueno por simplificar si tú tienes
un ETF que tiene cuatro años y tienes el futuro que tiene muchos más puedes
usar el futuro puedes usar el futuro y como dices tú dejar fuera de muestra el
ETF también probarlo en el mismo futuro pero también luego probarlo lógicamente
hay que vigilar lo que te decía temas de tic incluso tú a nivel de a nivel de
programación en este caso que también lo comentas podrías con dos datas
poner en ya luego para la operativa incluso te hablo es decir coger la
señal del futuro que es donde los backtesteado y luego lanzar la orden al
ETF podrías podrías hacerlos esto hay veces que lo que lo hacemos es decir
utilizar un código un activo para el backtest y otro para operar que repito
no siempre va a ser no es lo el escenario absolutamente ideal pero hay veces que
no hay otra alternativa me acuerdo entonces al final si no hay alternativa
pues hay que hacerlo no hay más siempre va a ser mejor conseguir un buen
backtest de una de una base de datos que tenga mucha correlación que no tener
y luego a más rugat te refieres a esto de la supervisión de sistemas es que yo
creía que sí que habíamos hablado de ello a ver decías supervisión de
sistemas operamos en algún ex la supervisión la hace entre este son
corriendo los mismos sistemas con los mismos parámetros pregunta si
principalmente si para ver el informe de expresión vía prince alberto si es
correcto o sólo corre los sistemas de interés y cuando hay alarma en el
protocolo de supervisión no nosotros los sistemas los tenemos cargados en los dos
sitios siempre están operando y simultáneamente están siempre
intereseción corriendo a nivel de supervisión
de supervisión y de hecho ya te digo incluso si hay alguna
descoordinación entre el life y el backtest el que manda nuestro protocolo
este es casualmente hoy que la verdad que pasa muy pocas veces porque con el
tiempo más buscando la manera de que de que se repliquen bien hoy ha habido una
una pequeña diferencia hoy ha habido una pequeña diferencia en la operación y se
ha tenido que ajustar es decir ha salido ha salido una orden en meta que no ha
salido en el futuro entonces esto nosotros lo revertimos lo revertimos
porque el que manda es el futuro del futuro que ya te digo hay una serie de
ajustes en un código y en otro para para tratar de que sean análogos pero a
veces pues pues pasa que no entonces espero ahora que si en este caso claro
se identifica la orden claro no no es que la paramos es que bueno si lo si es
que ya digo es algo que pasa muy muy poco por lo tanto entonces no es algo que
pase ni tan solo pasa para que me entiendas cada mes de acuerdo es decir
puede pasar no sé dos veces al año no dos veces al año puede pasar una vez al
año sabes decir de este orden en este orden entonces sí como una época que
pasaba un poco más porque ya lo había comentado pero ahora hablamos de este de
este momento si lo si nos damos cuenta antes que hoy no ha sido así vale si
nos damos cuenta antes que hoy no ha sido así pues evidentemente se anula si
es un orden para abrir pero en este caso ya digo no nos hemos dado cuenta antes
y nos hemos dado cuenta porque se ha ejecutado una orden que no se debería
haber ajustado pues lo que se ha hecho es cerrar la posición sin más se ha cerrado
la posición porque pues había hecho una operativa una operación incorrecta pero
repito esto hablamos de una o dos veces al año
esto está parcialmente automatizado en darnos cuenta pero tampoco está
totalmente automatizado y la solución es el manejo no hay ningún procedimiento
aquí automático para solucionarlo porque eso que te digo se podría
implementar si se podía implementar vale la pena no vale la pena porque el
tiempo de desarrollo luego encima también puede fallar no vale la pena hay
que ser pragmático y lo que os digo siempre hay que tener en cuenta el tiempo
que dispones los recursos que tienes sean humanos sean de tiempo sea de
software de todo y aprovecharlos en la mejor manera que puedes y eso implica
como ya os he explicado que hay cosas que se pueden mejorar y siempre va a ser así
de hecho y asumirlo y tratar de mejorarlas tratar de conseguir más
recursos para mejorarlas las que no puedes etcétera pero hay que
no todo es perfecto ni idílico porque a lo mejor desarrollarlo de la manera
idílica pues supone una cantidad de horas que prefiero dedicar a otra cosa
entonces eso eso es así entonces este tipo de fallos tan puntuales se resuelve
a maneja vale vamos vamos con donde nos nos quedamos bueno a mí he subido ahí en
materia habéis visto en material que subí los dos pdf es de queda el de la
intradía vale todavía no lo no lo tenemos acabado alberto por favor
apúntatelo para hacerlo mañana ya sin falta vale ahora ya que tenemos la clase
mañana hacemos ese ese es intradía y si yo lo dejaría hecho aunque luego por
ejemplo porque si si el mil reversión 0 3 el mil reversión intradía que ahora
de hecho vamos a enseñar falta falta hacer el pdf si si ves ahí el viernes el
viernes estuve yo haciendo estos dos y los subí ahí al disco el uno y el dos
los subí entonces ya queda el 3 queda el 3 y ahora vamos de hecho a enseñarlo
brevemente comentar alguna cosita respecto respecto a él vale pero
faltaría de esa clase faltaría el pdf luego faltará los de la semana que viene
ya os digo que sin duda sin duda que estos van a trabajar tanto el mil
reversión de la semana pasada como el tendencial de hoy ambos con bollinger
estos seguro que con salidas los vamos a los vamos a mejorar de hecho ya lo hemos
mejorado un poco pero que seguro que lo vamos a vamos a poder conseguir una
versión más aprovechable más debería del de la semana pasada que el de que el
de ésta porque el de ésta es un sistema apto para muy pocos activos un
sistema apto para muy pocos activos pero para algunos lo es en la vez ratio que
ahora veremos cómo funciona y ya digo con con salidas y demás aprovecharemos
aprovecharemos para enseñar y trabajar un poquito lo que ya vimos en la teoría
de cientos salidas algunas y lo trabajaremos por código lo explicaremos
para aquel que no trabaje con ese lenguaje puede adaptar y veremos un poco
algo que comentó en el debate que tuvimos la semana pasada con aquellos
filtros de hongar y demás y eso podría hacerse con otras cosas y yo le
contesté efectivamente de hecho en la en la teoría lo visteis
no me acuerdo cuál era ahora en el 5 3 5 6 3 me suena de memoria pero no me
dais mucho caso donde enseñe distintos tipos de salida en un código pues bueno
esto ya lo hemos evolucionado un poco más y aquí al martes que viene pues
todavía lo evolucionaremos un poco más y veremos distintas salidas para poder
aplicar a distintas entradas que es bastante sencillo a fortuna en otros
lenguajes hay que implementarlo a lo mejor de
a lo mejor no hay que implementarlo todo junto en el mismo código en cambio
nisi lenguages también lo puedes hacer así pero lo puedes meter como un código
aparte de acuerdo meter las entradas por un lado las salidas por otra esto es
bastante interesante en ese lenguaje ya lo vemos el martes el martes que viene
vale venga a ver donde tengo yo lo de hoy a ver bueno en mi reversión no el
revertir antes tengo montes abiertos y como te has abierto con que con
tendencial vale vamos a ver antes en mi reversión a no sé si es este o este
yo creo que es este backfilling venga vamos alegría de verdad esto me tiene
negro esto me tiene negro pero si este ya lo abierto antes no no ahora está
quitado eso pues no eres acá ya que tres y lo tengo cerrado no pero tengo abierto
el tiempo real y no va a buquear eso ahora pues ahora lo veremos ahora lo
veremos parece que se queda conectado parece que se queda conectado pues voy
con ello bueno ya está ahí está mira es nada
pero de paciencia poco de paciencia es que bueno este para que
además bueno y ya de cara a la intradía podemos como lo hemos hecho alguna
evolución alberto pues queda que el hecho de no haberlo hecho pues casi casi
mejor bueno esta es la versión que ya vimos del
del volinger vans por el código acordaros simplemente compramos en banda
baja vendemos en banda alta y vimos distintas posibilidades de cara a la
salida de pes esto con atr sin atr vimos distintas distintas salidas vemos
algún filtro de adx de volatilidad hablamos de otros filtros desde donde
haya habido alguna alguna evolución salida
implementamos también varias salidas una de ellas en la banda contraria vale es
quizá la más la más razonable y también hablábamos de trabajar con filtros
horarios aquí porque no hay con un trade es así no puede ser no 11 10
bueno porque está filtrando no y si está operando es es que es lo que lo que
está parado no no es que es que es que vamos aquí a un barco algo de pronto
deja de operar mira lo ves que hace que no pere y hoy vamos a para la operativa
aquí porque qué ha pasado aquí es algo de las horas es la base de datos 2016
ya bueno pero pero si se ha cargado se ha cargado no hay nada no no hay filtro
24 de la derecha pero es al final pero es otro es otro otro código no entiendo
porque antes estaba ese abogado superas al final a ver si es el filtro pero no
tiene mucho sentido 11 no actúa pero cero no tiene sentido tiene un tipo ahora
esto se ha abogado el código a partir del 16 de ópera no sé por qué pero no
pero le voy a hacer control r lo que pasa es que eso supone el reloj a todo iba a irse a
tomar un ratito como dices son cosas del directo lo que pasa por hacer los
juegos en directo eso se hacen vídeo para ser vídeo pasará la teoría también
pasaba lo que pasa que es lo que digo para ser vídeo y luego lo empalmas y
esa es el tema pero ahora de pronto aquí además es que no entiendo por qué yo
creo que tiene que ser un back de la base de datos que ha dejado de leer las
horas se ha quedado en ventana que no opera no no no lo he cambiado yo antes
abierto si si yo lo he cambiado hasta el final luego no sé por qué bueno voy a
abrir el de tres station como íbamos a hacer antes y pero este este de tres
eso no lo teníamos con lo de abajo vamos a ver aquí tenía yo creo que lo había
puesto a ver si mientras carga lo monto lo monto aquí en tres 2 2
panda true 2 0 0 y sin filtros a faltar el data 2 claro no hay un entero de aquí
increíble verdad lo estoy montando a los hemos dado tres eso no os penséis que
estoy esperando sólo lo estoy votando entre seis y en breve lo tendré porque
ya lo tenía aquí está el 1 pero no tenía el 2 aquí está el uno también y
aquí también está el uno montamos aquí aquí sí que sacó dos datas creo que
era así ya está si si entre seis son ya ha cargado todos los trades y ahí está
bueno menos lo podemos lo podemos ver a menos lo podemos ver mientras no carga
si este en el 10 era donde te mejoraba mucho verdad o no mucho tampoco
de cortos y la 10 verdad alberto así mejora poquísimo el filtro de cortos de
11 a 10 esto sigue así que pasamos de él pasamos de él y en por qué
capitular recordaros que este es el sistema que ya os pasé este ya lo
subimos que era el el test que hicimos para una revista os lo recopilé así en
un artículo nuestro esto lo habíamos hecho
lo habíamos hecho para no me recuerdo que revista vale y aquí probamos distintas
versiones y bueno poquito con había algunas algunas métricas y demás no
simplemente un test un test sencillo con distintas medias en las bandas en
distintos futuros y bueno pues ahí podéis podéis compararlo jugar y así
tenéis una referencia de qué activos pues va un poco mejor este tipo de
estrategia lógicamente en las materias primas va mal suele ir mal y donde suele
ir un poco mejor puede ser en bolsa puede ser en bonos vale es un poco el
inicio es un poco el sitio donde puede ser que vaya que vaya mejor en la
mayoría iba iba bastante bastante flojo sobre todo en eso está hecho en diario
eso está en diario vale
y la única diferencia ya para acabar y pasarme al tendencial que había más
probado era la aplicación de algunos de algunos filtros vale algunos filtros en
largo y en el corto probamos ya de manera sencilla
no tengo cargado aquí no tengo cargado muy poco
es un poquito más aquí entiendo que va a ir un poco más rápido porque ya lo si
es que en el otro también lo tenía abierto o sea también lo había ya
cargado los datos lo que pasa es que al cargar mal el código la única solución
es recargar los datos entonces pues la cosa se complica la cosa se complica
como veis además se complica se complica más de lo que se complica si
no estás en directo porque estar en directo consume bastantes recursos y
entonces siempre todo pues va un poco más o que tenga un ordenador realmente
potente aún así estás emitiendo en directo en streaming y además estás
grabando y además estás con tres estación abierto y demás si puedo
un poco de recursos gráficos pero vaya el procesador ahí está ya nos ha cargado
tres station el otro sigue aún sigue cargando bueno aquí sencillamente teníamos
la versión misma así es como estaba así creo que está sin sin filtros si creo
que está sin filtros si conoce 11 está sin filtros simplemente está filtrado
pues la entrada y la salida y vamos ahí y ahí está está que es algo
congestión monetaria que trae lo decente lado corto muy cojo corto está ahí con
dificultad con filtros es lo que quería enseñaros porque montichar nos permite
enseñar la curva de los dos lados por eso estoy insistiendo en él no es que
tenga un cabricho es que al final aquí nos puede enseñar la curva de largos y
cortos y en montichar sí que puedo entonces pues esa era la gracia un poco
esa era un poco la gracia pero pues la gracia pues no de momento no va a poder
ser y por otro lado es lo que os digo aquí hay unos cuantos filtros que estuvo
trabajando alberto ayudándose un poquito de fuerza bruta estuvo explorando un
poquito algunos algunos filtros esto es un poco lo que lo que hablamos con
me preguntó de húnger y se son filtros de este tipo que puedes encontrar en
muchas revisas y que ahora os voy a enseñar algunos de ellos son filtros
sencillos en el fondo ya ya son todos provienen de velas cuando hablamos de
los rb vimos muchos conceptos sobre sobre ellos narrow range inside bar
outside bar cierre positivo cierre negativo cierre mayor que máximo menor
que filtro es realmente sencillos vale ahora ya se había cargado bien ahora
veis hemos mejorado un poquito la pata corta hemos mejorado un poquito la pata
corta sin ser nada de espectacular sin ser nada nada espectacular aquí seguimos
teniendo a la semana que viene lo trabajaremos mi opinión aquí hay camí
camino de mejora había salidas recuerdo el camino de mejor había salidas porque
en uno en un sistema de este tipo contra tendencial es importante tener salidas
más o menos rápidas y es verdad que estamos dejando correr bastante estamos
dejando correr bastante problemas siempre son las las perdedoras en este caso
especialmente porque es verdad que acertamos cuando sentamos vamos muy bien
pero vez tenemos enganchadas muy muy que es no por esa que se cortó y ahí es
donde realmente habría que salir que camino hay bien si vía pérdida no lo
conseguimos que es muy habitual es muy habitual que la pérdida siempre en peor
en peor el sistema pero es que enganchada aquí esto no puede ser es
evidente que esto tiene camino de mejora no estamos de acuerdo no vale una una
solución ya la semana que ven lo probamos pero ya os adelanto alguna una
solución que viene bien cuando no encontramos solución vía
pérdida típico stop de pérdida o tal es salida temporal salida temporal porque
al final a el tiempo en las prácticas la teoría lo vimos acuerdos que os lo
comenté salida en n barras o diferenciando se puede si se quiere
diferenciar entre ganadoras y perdedoras pero fijaros que acordaros
que un sistema porque un sistema antitenencial como este acordaros que
lo que tiene es un porcentaje de aciertos elevado recuerdo tiene un
porcentaje de aciertos elevado un porcentaje de aciertos que es 50% al
final la salida todo el sistema debe ser coherente lógicamente pero para aplicar
las salidas es muy importante el sentido común y
el sentido común al final se va educando un poco con la experiencia la
práctica que quiere decir que yo tengo un porcentaje de salidas elevado en este
caso es del 60 por ciento acordaros que ahí siempre se mueven uno en contra del
otro acuerdo si yo acierto mucho quiere decir que tengo un ratio a ver a ver
los bajos que en este caso incluso es inferior a 1 es inferior a 1 y esto en la
práctica en la práctica que quiere decir quiere
decir que tengo perdedoras muy grandes en relación a las ganadoras o sea que
tengo mayores perdedoras que ganadoras vale y también que mi pérdida media es
mayor que mi ganancia media vale y que y que en cualquier caso mis pérdidas en
valor monetario pues corren más corren más que mis ganancias vale por lo tanto
si yo pongo una salida por tiempo a ver este dato lo tenemos aquí fijaros un
momentito que estoy buscando un dato en el performance report pero no lo
encuentro aquí aquí aquí aquí aquí vale ahora cuando multichars cargos
multichars y carga un seguido de estos y no lo cerraré porque parece que está
poco colgado vale es el performance report de ese sistema es igual más allá del
resultado ahora mismo me da un poco igual pero eso que os decía de aciertos a ver
un poquito que me abro lo de marcar la pantalla
me lo parto aquí porcentaje de aciertos espérate voy a hacer que esto
desaparezca en un ratito así no se queda y parece vale lo que decía
prontas aciertos 62 por ciento vale lógicamente más en los largos que los
cortos pero aún así los cortos también por encima de 50 como veis vale y eso
implica un ratio a ver a ver a los de 0 85 que además es igual en este caso es
igual en largos y cortos y eso que significa que la media de tri ganador
5.700 vale es menor ahora se irá que la de perdeón en valor absoluto
lógicamente es mayor la pérdida vale y esto también se traduce en otra cosa
frecuentemente frecuentemente que esa cosa estaba ahora tratando de enseñar
vale yo aquí tengo los tiempos medios espera que voy a cambiar a cuadrado
aquí los tiempos medios vale vemos el tiempo medio de generar una operación
pero fijaros que las ganadoras están mucho menos tiempo que las perdedoras
las ganadoras están mucho menos tiempo quiere decir que quiere decir esto
porque eso quería enseñar porque eso es lo que hay detrás lo que hay detrás de
que salir por tiempo suele suele rentar por no es decir porque porque cuando yo
me quedo mucho tiempo normalmente es para perder cuando acierto suelo hacer
los rápidos lógicamente hay excepciones pero de media de media cuando acierto
hago las ganancias antes que las pérdidas en valor absoluto por lo tanto
cuando yo no consigo mejorarlo vía salida sea absoluta sea porcentual sea
lo que sea una de las maneras salir por tiempo la semana que viene jugaremos con
esto pero es probable lo veremos que la salida por tiempo nos ayude a evitar esto es decir yo
pongo una salida que puedo diferenciar si estoy en ganancias o estoy perdida y puedo diferenciarlo
pero incluso sin diferenciarlo por no sobre optimizar veréis que es probable que nos rente
salir en n barras porque porque es usted que se va a quedar enganchado al final pues si no
si no cierra por su objetivo pues se sale pasa las que sean parras y se sale y vas a evitar quedarte
mucho tiempo porque veréis que rara vez o casi nunca esto no nos lo si nos lo dice tres
que sí espérate expand sí creo que sí que nos lo dice no nos lo dice no nos lo dice el run up
bueno nos dice el mayor si el mayor una podemos ir a verlo sí sí sí que nos lo dices es nos lo
dicen valor medio esta análisis de aquí es aquí de los run ups y los drawdowns vale esto esto es
referido a los trades de acuerdo es decir no está diciendo que el trade que más valor acumulado ha
sido 88 pero fijaros que la pérdida que más acumulado 121 nos da las fechas que es normal que
sean cercanas porque es por volatilidad y también nos da el valor medio de los run ups y de los
drawdowns de los trades repito de los trades siempre es mayor como veis la pérdida vale
también la primera desviación entonces al final esto es lo que os digo que suele llevar a salidas
temporales rentar bastante en este tipo de sistemas en un tendencial es distinto en un
tendencial es distinto porque es justo lo contrario entonces ahí a lo mejor no me renta
tanto en un tendencial no renta nada que quite colas o sea que vale todo este tipo de salidas suelen
mejorar anti tendenciales microversión de acuerdo sistemas intradiarios incluso break out puede
mejorar pero un tendencial puro no es habitual que lo mejore un tendencial puro hay pocas salidas
que puedan que puedan ayudar a mejorar esto que no sean casuales o fruto de la sobreutilización
porque un tendencial necesita estos trades de muy largo recorrido para ser rentable porque acierta
muy poco entonces pasa justo lo contrario ahí veréis run ups muy largos y perdidas menores vale
pero aquí estamos en la situación contraria por lo tanto cualquier trade o cualquier salida
que a mí me saque del mercado simplemente por tiempo sin tener en cuenta si va bien si gano
si pierdo normalmente me va a me va a rentar porque me va a quitar más pérdidas que ganadoras se
entiende sobre aún así también se puede hacer la regla repito si hay suficiente trade puedo hacerlo
se puede hacer la regla de decir si estoy en pérdidas salir en n barras si no siempre
días no entiendes decir si open position profit es menor que cero vale aplico la salida en n barra
si no no lo aplico por ejemplo pero fijaros que siempre los perdedores suelen que veréis muy
pocas flechas alguna hay pero está pero pero ha estado en pérdidas juegues ganadoras que
sean muy largas de tiempo me refiero mira esas seguramente de las más de las más largas pero
no es nada no es nada habitual bien tema filtros que os decía bueno que algunos estamos hoy bien
con la técnica estamos muy bien un momentito para el control de los chicos mientras tanto voy a
cerrar a ver todo porque creo que ya no va a cargar está el ciego sin guardar el ciego
sin guardar y lo vuelvo a intentar abrir porque para el otro me iría bien que se abriera
espérate adiós bueno se ha colgado el orcado al principio sí pero de momento aguanta parece
el principio también se cuelga antes de eso cuando se colga eso es bueno lo que os decía vale tenemos
unos filtros para largos unos filtros para corto roberto estaba buscando algunos y esto sí que los
ha hecho en una en una función vale esto ya os lo ya os lo pasaremos también cuando hagamos el pdf
pegadito código y todo para que lo para que lo veáis vale está hecho con dos datos para que
sea de manera de manera sencillo y como os conté hay un switch de diversos que es porque así tú
puedes llamar a cada una de ellas de manera muy sencilla vale siempre se hace así poniéndola
una de ellas que la deja en true y una de ellas que la deja en false que normalmente es la última
porque así en caso de que te equivoques pues simplemente ves que no actúa si tú le pones 12
no no hará ningún trade porque le dará valor false a la función y no operará vale en cambio
el caso contrario se ponen 11 que siempre es truque decir que por lo tanto es no filtrar de
esa manera tú puedes incorporar la función en cualquier esto siempre es así lo que cambia
es no deja de ser una plantilla un selector vale esto se hace así para las salidas así para para
todo vale es decir es un selector a que se van haciendo de si en dos que es de esa manera tu
llamando ese selector en tu condición de entrada es le dices aquí si close tal tal tal y filtro
clase tú es true de acuerdo la función es true entonces pues puede puede comprar y si no pues
puede puede poder abrir o sea puede abrir largos o puede abrir cortos vale hay una un input para
largos y otro para cortos porque así le puedes poner un valor distinto de acuerdo y cuando es
cada cada una de ellas true bueno alberto ha probado varias de distinto tipo que lo que
decía probar algunas realmente es que hay a montones librerías por ahí ya os pasaremos
algunas y la semana que viene que nos dedicaremos un poco sólo a hacerse a practicar este tipo con
selectores pensado más para la salida pero como os digo es una herramienta que se utiliza también
para filtros y para todo así que lo lo veremos un poco para todo pero sobre todo sobre todo como
digo para las salidas que implican bueno por eso que os digo este simplemente valora que el cierre
sea menor que la apertura diaria vale esto lo tienes lo ha definido aquí arriba lo podías saber
es más fácil hacerlo como como lo hecho como lo hecho alberto porque si no pues hay que hacerlo
con las reyes y demás es muy complicado pero así así es bastante sencillo simplemente pues
guardas el valor de cada de cada una de las campos de la barra open high low close y le le asignas
una variable vale para no estar cada cada vez escribiendo hay tal no sé qué vale sobre todo
porque en este caso está referido a un data 2 y habría que escribir cada vez hay o data 2 lo
entonces lo ha guardado ya todo aquí en una variable open de 0 es open data 2 hay de 0 es
hay porque en el data 2 está en diario de acuerdo el data 2 en este caso está en diario por eso le
llama de pero realmente en este en este en este caso podría haberse haberse hecho porque en
easy language existe esta palabra pero lo hemos hecho así para simplificar o sea en easy language
existe el close de es el cierre diario vale se puede ser una función que llama cierre diario
vale ya lo tiene lo tiene implementado tres es el igual que el hike tú desde una entrada y haces
hike de eso es el máximo diario aunque estés en una entrada vale así así queda mucho más
queda mucho más claro vale queda muchísimo más más claro y hay distintos distintos filtros por
no alargarnos tampoco a tetérnum en este en verlos 1 1 1 hora que ya repito que esto os lo pasaré
en ese sistema en el caso largo que era algo probable no no es seguro pero es probable porque
en el lado largo no hay mucho problema en el sentido de que pues siempre vas a operar a favor
de tendencia y por lo tanto es más sencillo de acuerdo que no haga que no sea necesario filtrar
entradas porque acordaros que estás en una antitencial y que por lo tanto ya estás entrando
en una cierta sobreventa para ir largo de acuerdo es decir cuando va a entrar largo cuando el precio
ha caído un poco no porque para ir a la banda abajo y cerrar por debajo tiene que haber caído
vale entonces en un activo que tiene una evidente tendencia alcista de largo plazo comprar cuando
cae pues normalmente es más probable que sea buena cosa que vender entonces normalmente puede
ser que no haga falta filtrar no es no es no quiere decir que sea imposible encontrar un filtro para
mejorar largo que quede claro pero a priori es algo que puede que es que es fácil donde está donde
está el trabajo lógicamente aquí es para mejorar los cortos y de hecho hemos encontrado que los
mejora un poco pero sólo un poco es realmente tiene bastante campo de mejora de mejora vale porque
donde ha habido quizá más mejores en la ventana horaria en trabajar unas ventanas horarias que se
centra mucho intenta aprovechar una pauta que seguro que habéis oído hablar que no se centra
solo en ella pero indirectamente en la pauta del overnight vale que por cierto lleva tiempo
funcionando mal pero hay mucha gente que opera sistemas de overnight porque durante muchos
años tanto la subida blsp del nasa que ha estado más de los dos tercios de ella centrada en el
overnight de acuerdo es decir venía el mercado con gap y una vez abría el mercado regular la
de media la subida era era inferior a la que había habido durante el overnight es decir desde que
cierra wall street a las 14 a la apertura del día siguiente tres y media no entonces aquí por
ejemplo el filtro que nos ha venido saliendo era justamente ese es decir se a abrir justo
cuando el mercado está cerrando a partir de las cinco y media que es que cierran tres y media regular
pues a partir de ahí empezar a buscar entradas ahí porque porque hay un sesgo ahí pues tengo
que poder largo poder corto y seguramente otra posible mejora cuidado con la sobre optimización
es las ventanas temporales trabajarlas distintas vale es recomendable hacerlo bueno tiene riesgo de
sobre optimización lógicamente es decir hay que hay que hay que vigilar hay que tener una muestra
muy significativa muchos años hay que vigilar pero en entraría pensar que siempre hay más margen es
lo que la teoría insistíamos mucho en esto no es lo mismo trabajar un sistema que va más
diaria a un entradía de 240 un entradía ya no te digo 30 sino 15 minutos imagínate a veces
puedes hacer eso decir bueno pues sabes que voy a hacer voy a bajar time frame mantengo histórico
porque quiero representatividad pero si voy a buscar operar más claro que no me sirve luego
bajar a 15 minutos y hacer 503 explico decir si voy a conseguir a lo mejor 5000 operaciones
entiendes si a lo mejor consigo 5000 operaciones pues entiendes siempre es mejor de acuerdo siempre
es mejor voy a ganar ahí mucha significación y puedo aumentar mi puedo decir bueno pues voy
a probar en este caso a separar el tiempo a ver qué veo si mi análisis da que no me da una gran
diferencia pues no lo cambio entiendes decir si en una me sale que entro 15 30 y la otra me sale
las 4 no lo cambio es decir sólo lo cambiaría el mismo criterio que decía antes hablando con
rubén en el disc or que sea significativa la mejora es decir que lo mismo si yo voy a separar
largos y cortos tengo que hacerlo teniendo una muestra muy importante de trades teniendo una
representatividad de mercados muy elevada es una práctica de riesgo y hay mucha gente que no le
gusta a mí personalmente me gusta mucho pero es verdad que hay que tener claro que aumenta el
riesgo de sobreutilizar es decir es así y por eso que gente que no es partidaria es verdad que yo
he operado casi toda mi vida muchos sistemas que operaban el mercado de acciones entonces claro
tengo eres un poco fruto de tu experiencia pero vengo de ahí y ahí es donde más falta haces
si tú ya vas a mercados más simétricos no hace no hace tanta falta y entonces es peor
práctica pero en acciones es muy buena práctica pero cuidado con la con sobre ajustarse a lo mejor
también podemos encontrar ventanas distintas horarias hay que vigilar con esto que os digo seguro
casi seguro está apuntado para probarlo alberto de probar la de la versión 3 que hay ventana
distinta para largo que para corto ventana distinta en vez de hacer 2 no haría 2 y 2 es decir
me explicó decir podemos hacer un lo que haría es un una hora de entrada de corto una hora de
entrada de largo y un número de barras vale para los 2 un número de barras para los 2 si para
quitar una variable para quitar un input así tendrías 3 en vez de 4 si porque no va a ser va
a ser más crítico la hora que si le das 3 4 5 6 barras me explico es decir tú crees bueno
no trabajamos no trabajamos no trabajamos pero pero iba a variar mucho porque si te fijas esta
esta búsqueda de horas te ha dado claramente la ventana nocturna y la ventana la ventana nocturna
entiendes entonces la corta nunca te va a dar eso yo creo que la corta te va a dar todo la
contraria te va a dar probablemente probablemente cerca de las ocho las nueve exactamente probablemente
te va a buscar cortos entre las ocho las nueve me me sospecho esto esto es lo que os digo de la
de la experiencia de la sensibilidad de lo del mercado pero hay que verlo entonces probablemente
te va a dar eso te va a buscar ventanas distintas y esto de verdad no no no es mala práctica esto
es ya ya en intradía no sólo nos malas no que es buena práctica de acuerdo las ventanas horarias
entre ellas son claves ya os lo comenté y no tienen porque ir sobre todo en acciones si esto
lo estuvieramos haciendo en otro activo es otra cosa me refiero oro me refiero petróleo me refiero
cacao zumo naranja es decir soja lo que sea en acciones largo y cortos no tienen nada que ver
no tiene nada que ver casi en nada ni en horas ni en dinámica ni en duración de trades volatilidad
vale es como otra cosa es como otro activo entonces hacerlo juntos que hay que hacerlo
junto bueno pues no sé por qué hay que hacerlo junto es decir puedes buscar un equilibrio si
bueno esto es como si tú tienes un coche y lo hay y tienes que ir a correr en un circuito tienes
que ir a correr por la montaña puedes montar un coche equilibrado entre las dos cosas seguramente
si puedes pero no irá bien ni en uno ni en otro estamos de acuerdo porque en la montaña necesitarás
amortiguadores altos altura del suelo muy elevada unas ruedas muy altas y en el circuito necesitas
de suelo rueda muy ancha perfil bajo porque no puedes pinchar es distinto habrán momentos que
a mejor no puedo permitirme tener dos setas distintos pues busco un intermedio bueno en el
caso del coche puede ser por pasta puede ser por lo que sea porque me lo obliga al reglamento pero
pero aquí si no puedo por tres por significado vale pues perfecto pero si yo me voy a ir a la
entrada y si puedo pues si tentémoslo si vemos que es parecido no lo hago si vemos que no lo veo
robusto pues no lo hago hay que hay que lógicamente tener mayor precaución el precaución pero sí que
lo haría y en un antitenencial donde ya digo donde busco ventanas donde busco entrar y salir
y quedarme pues x tres dos días tres días no busco swing un largo recorrido busco estar
en el mercado relativamente poco tiempo es bastante importante en qué horas aumento y aquí digo
ahí hay versiones este yo creo que la semana que viene tenemos una versión un poquito más rápida
que esta creo haciendo esto creo que conseguiremos una versión un poquito más rápida es decir que
estén menos tiempo en el mercado que el que tenemos estamos ahora pensando en la en esto de
las salidas que os digo en esto de las salidas que os digo trabajando trabajando ventanas horarias
salidas por separado incluyendo casi con total seguridad la salida temporal como os decía porque
nos va a cubrir muy bien las malas las malas comenta mario lo comento ahora ya sé que digo
siempre al final pero como va muy ligado y seguramente no saldrá más esto si el tema el tema
de los suites que son sólo para hacer el testeo bueno también puede ser por cuestiones de
configuración del sistema o sea y comenta el que siempre es bueno dejar los códigos sencillos si
sí es cierto pero es que un case es sencillo esa pues no tiene nada al final el que es piensa que
además a mí me gusta mucho esto es el lenguaje está ya está ya está el que es escondido al final
tú lo tienes en un bloque begin en y tal pero bueno si si tú luego cuando quieres dejar el
sistema ya limpio lo dejas el filtro implementado y el resto fuera puedes hacerlo pero piensa que
esto es la función o sea esto no es el código el código al final llama a la función o sea es
una línea de acuerdo es decir la función lo que sí que es buena y buena práctica trabajar con
funciones para no no no tenerlo todo puesto en él en el código de manera más sencilla de
final es más más más limpio pero tú al final la línea que usa esto en el sistema es esta es esa
son es una palabra es la función sí que lleva su trabajo y su historia vale bueno no las hemos
mirado pero que ya os digo todas tienen que ver normalmente todas tienen que ver con figuras de
como se decía de velas o el tamaño de la vela expansiones de volatilidad como se mida una expansión
de volatilidad pues eso aquí por ejemplo hay alguna de ellas es verdad que la primera vez que
la vez es como no intuitiva pero esto al final esto que veis aquí es una expansión de volatilidad
te está diciendo que el máximo recordar que hay de cero está aquí definido es el data 2 por
tanto es diario es decir yo estoy en el entraría pero estoy usando una vela diaria para referirme
para para mirar si ha habido expansión vale es decir por lo tanto en el fondo estoy mirando
el del día anterior no sé si esto se entiende voy a voy a voy a explicarlo un poco un poco más
en el gráfico esto es porque esto es verdad que no lo he explicado y para para usuarios no muy
familiarizados con esta herramienta puede me acaba dar cuenta que puede ser por sentar una cosa que
no hay que dar la rectificó la rectificó vuelvo vuelvo el gráfico vale data 1 arriba 30 minutos
data 2 abajo diario de acuerdo es el mismo activo en este caso podría ser otro en este caso no lo
es en este caso no lo es que se vea más allá ya está pensaba que estaba estaba adiós no te creo
no te creo que todo no no no se comparte la cámara para que no vean mis mis caras de decepción
frustración indignación y ganas de destruir el pc hoy que tengo es le he quitado para para eso
bueno pues nada ya veis el mensaje sí sí sí no guardes no guardes nada vamos para casa para casa
todos a casa a dormir en fin está esta flamenco y justo antes de justo antes de arrancar nos ha
saltado una de tres sesiones no lo he instalado y he dudado porque ya ya os lo comenté que
estábamos notando y también en multicharts algunos fallos últimamente porque hubieron nuevas
versiones y bueno pues es lo que pasa con las nuevas con las nuevas versiones esto acaba por
cierto esto acabado pero sigue sin hacer tres tío yo no entiendo lo has abierto esto todo abierto
abréntelo por favor abréntelo y mira y mira a ver qué pasa porque no me abre a mí es que
a ver si hay algún baque en el código que no que sin querer hemos metido algo yo creo pero no lo
sé es el dos el dos de principio no nos cambió el código pero no sé decirte porque es raro
es raro que multicharts haga eso no sé que es por error pues ha dado f3 o algo no sé no sé
no sé darte una explicación razonable a lo que pasa hoy entonces cuando no hay razonables pues
hay que buscar ya un poco raras no no que es el dos porque la ventana derecha está el tres
olvídate mira que la de la izquierda te habrá pero sí lo exportado por cierto y lo exportado en todo
caso oído voy a volver a abrir ahora empieza por tres sesiones a ver si va mejor así había
cerrado el cron también porque traga una de recursos que no tiene sentido alguno de las
casas en directo tiene esto que dices tiene lo tiene su tiene su cosa buena no pero pero tiene
su cosa mala es su cosa mala es que claro aunque aunque aunque las caras y están bastante preparadas
pero siempre hay algo que quieres enseñar en directo que cambias que abres que cierras y al
final encima aquí que estás dependiendo de multicharts que te abre los histórico de
tres station y es una conexión que es verdad que a veces pues es un poco inestable pues pues ya
la ves ya ves la que tienes a ver venga voy a abrir de momento abro tres station o que si
abro tres tengo el one drive parado pero bueno pues mira ves aquí parece que ahora abre bien
en el momento me quedo aquí vale ya abriré luego multicharts me quedo aquí porque aquí
es donde estaba ahora y no me hace falta nada más no me hace falta nada más venga bueno está
cargando datos se ha bogueado él se ha bogueado el caché me ha salido un mensaje que se había
dañado el caché alberto así que ahora veremos pero bueno yo sigo sigo donde estaba sigo donde
lo que os diga lo que se decía arriba tenemos un 30 minutos de acuerdo cargado con todo el horario
disponible del sb 500 que son pues casi 23 horas y abajo tenemos un diario de acuerdo donde se
alinean los datos lógicamente se alinean a una hora que es al cierre esta es la práctica común
excepto meta tener por ejemplo que es otra cosa pero da igual no importa ahora no nos perdamos
en la barra de cierre se alinean quiere decir que hasta durante hoy mira mira lo vais a ver
súper fácil cargando tiempo real lo vais a ver súper fácil cargando tiempo real y ahora cargo
tiempo real cargó tiempo real y si no se rompe nada a mí me está así que me está dibujando la
diaria podemos decir a futuro pero como veis no me deja consultarla es decir yo yo ahora no
tengo acceso al cierre diario esto es obvio no es obvio por lo tanto si yo ahora consulto el cierre
diario el cierre que estoy consultando es este se entiende durante el día de hoy el cierre último
diario es este es decir si yo cuando abre el mercado que es aquí recordar que esto es el
cierre de recordar que aquí para que lo voy a lo voy a poner en en el mismo terras y son porque
aquí no se va aquí esta es la vela de cierre esta de ahí y abajo pues pues la misma de acuerdo
la misma esa es la vela de cierre intradía y abajo tengo la vela de cierre diaria en esa
va en esa en esa barra si yo ejecuto el código ahí que arriba se ejecutan todas las velas al cierre
de cada vela de acuerdo en esa vela yo consulto el cualquier dato y están alineadas y si que
coinciden en el tiempo pero a partir de la siguiente de acuerdo a partir de la siguiente vela la
cada cada vela de 30 minutos cada vela de 30 minutos que cierra cualquiera de ellas voy a
apuntar la hora en círculo para que sea otra imaginaros esta de acuerdo el código del isil en
web se procesa y lógicamente le evaluará dónde está el precio si cierra por debajo de la banda
si se va por encima por lo que sea las reglas del código de acuerdo el evaluar esta vela pero
si yo le consulto algún dato de la diaria es obvio verdad que es obvio aquí ahora lo
veis pero hay que entenderlo a nivel de evaluación es obvio que no puede consultar esta no es obvio
no la que está consultando es esta por lo tanto cuando yo estoy usando un filtro diario lo que
estoy valorando puedo valorar datos de esta pero los compararía con los compararía con la con la
anterior de acuerdo con el cierre de ayer se entiende si me refiero a la diaria me referiría
al datos de la vela de ayer o de anteriores y quisiera en cambio a las velas de intradía me
puede referir a la actual el anterior anterior a las que quiera bien volvemos un poco al isil
entonces yo cuando estoy consultando lo voy a dejar aquí en el lateral para que se veáis eso
cuando yo estoy consultando un filtro y aquí veis todos estos datos que ha calculado alberto se
refieren al data 2 vale y el open cuando no pone nada es 0 es decir el open 0 es esa que veis roja
ese es el open 0 esta es el open 0 esta de aquí la primera el open 1 es la del día anterior y
el anterior y lo mismo para el close para el high para el logo vale esto que estoy seguro que
mucha gente está diciendo esto es obvio estoy seguro que hay otros que no vale que no que no
lo aumenta no vale entonces es importante entenderlo porque cuando yo estoy aquí buscando filtros que
están basados en la vela diaria o que comparan a lo mejor datos de la intradía con la diaria hay
que entender esto porque aquí lo veis muy claro pero es que esto en la penúltima del día también
pasa en la penúltima vela del día sigo consultando la diaria hasta que no estén alineadas es decir
hasta la vela de cierre intradía del día no estaré consultando no será la open 0 será la del día la
de hoy al cierre será la de la de hoy vale bien entiendo que todo el mundo esto lo ve claro si
alguien no lo ve claro o lo comenta por favor ahí en el chat entonces volviendo un poco a los
filtros alguno de ellos a ver alguno muy obvio vale aquí ves dice close de 1 open de 1 está de hecho
aquí alberto podíamos haber usado también el 0 podrías haber usado close de 0 no hemos hecho
pues por lo que sea porque hemos probado algunos entre entre muchos como ya os digo no deja de ser
un ejercicio para el día siguiente ya trataremos de afinarlo sobre todo insisto con las salidas
aquí sé que está el cierre fijaros que este close es la diferencia que es muy importante se
lee bien no en la pantalla alberto el código se le viene vale aquí fijaros esto recordar que
es lo mismo que close lo escribo para que para que así lo veáis más claro vale fijaros que aquí
no pone no pone la variable que ha guardado porque porque se está refiriendo al data 1 de
acuerdo es decir esto que está haciendo para que lo entendáis bien todo esto eso está comparando
el cierre de cualquiera de estas velas intradía de cualquiera de estas bueno en la que la que
analice en cuestión en cada momento no vale con aunque con el open con el open del día anterior
de acuerdo con el open del día anterior es decir con este valor de aquí con este
se va a corruptar la ventana no vale vale está siguiendo tú me estás siguiendo alberto también
la clase vale vale este compara el close de la vela que estemos en cuestión pues lo que
sé por ejemplo esta es hablando de esta regla para que entendáis la diferencia entre data 1
el close de esta con el open de cero que es la anterior diaria disponible esta podría haber
sido también con el close podría haber sido a mí me parece que es más lógico pero estos son
son filtros que están probados así que alberto ha elegido algunos pues ahora mismo no sé bajo
qué criterio el que sea no importa no importa porque la importante de las clases es la que
entendáis las cosas a medida que vamos avanzando pues también iremos sacando cosas más más acabadas
podemos decir pero sobre todo el importante es sacar las ideas y los conceptos eso lo he
insistido hasta la saciedad en todo el curso y hasta con alguien que ha hablado antes del curso
recuerdo que siempre me lo preguntaba oye pero salen muchos sistemas de curso del curso salen
algunos sistemas pero no es el objetivo no es el objetivo o sea no estáis comprando sistemas de
esfuerzo para comprar sistemas se compran los temas y punto es otra cosa estamos comprando
un curso y en un curso hay que aprender a aprender a hacer las cosas y entenderlas sobre todo entonces
al final entender tipos de filtros de este tipo donde digo pueden haber que hay aquí aquí que
compara por ejemplo a close de 1 bueno está está sí bueno está por ejemplo está comparando el
máximo de esta vela de la vela que tenemos encuadrada abajo vale para que entendáis mira
vamos a marcar uno este estos que son más complicados vale son más con más que tiene
más largos más largos vale el hay de esta vela que está marcada que sea mayor que el mínimo esto
es muy habitual porque es una manera de añadirle algo es decir es eso al final fijaros que estoy
añadiendo un precio un trozo de precio de acuerdo siguió al mínimo el mínimo es una
línea no se entiende mirar que es el mínimo el mínimo el mínimo a ver esperaros ahí el mínimo
que es el mínimo es esto eso es el mínimo es un punto un precio un número es un valor estamos
siguió a ese mínimo ahora he borrado el otro si a ese mínimo era el 3 le sumo algo de acuerdo
lo que estoy es comparando de acuerdo estoy comparando el precio son comparando un precio
con otro precio de acuerdo y estoy pidiéndole en este caso que el máximo sea mayor que el
mínimo más la mitad del mínimo por un multiplicador vale por un multiplicador que es un
porcentaje 0 0 1 es esa manera de hacerlo porcentaje vale entonces simplemente le estoy sumando la
mitad estoy multiplicando pues yo que sé en este caso para que entendáis 5.281 con 49 vale que
es el precio que se me ha quedado ahí marcado aleatoriamente pero vamos a suponer que sea ese
vale 1281 a ver si es escribir con 49 vale y le estoy sumando ese mismo número multiplicado
por 0 5 es decir la mitad entienden a la mitad estoy sumando que su sumando la mitad de la vela
no se sumando la mitad de la vela y lo multiplicó por 0 0 1 vale y eso que me da pues me da
concretamente 5307 me da otro precio de acuerdo porque pues me da este precio que es la mitad
bueno es un poco más de la mitad vale entonces lo que estoy pidiendo es que el máximo sea mayor
que eso explicaros que la misma regla por eso la puesto alberto para que yo os lo explicara se puede
hacer con 1.5 con 2.5 desde lo que estoy pidiendo es una mayor expansión del precio es pidiendo
una mayor expansión y puede ser mayor o puede ser menor puede pedir la expansión o contracción
pero es que la 5 pide que sea menor y la 3 y la 4 pide que sea mayor es decir una es una regla
de expansión y otra es una regla de contracción al final compara rangos de precios para rangos
de precios eso cuando va a ser truco no en este caso en esta vela por ejemplo estuvo porque es
una vela de expansión de gran expansión el máximo es mayor que eso pero si fuera una vela
chiquitita donde el máximo no se ha alejado mucho del mínimo tenés la idea el máximo no se ha
alejado mucho del mínimo eso sería false porque ese valor el 5307 sería por debajo del máximo
se entiende la idea si esto no lo miras en una vela que tienen menor rango vale sería false y
a medida que le voy aumentando el número pues le pido más expansión si lo miro con 1.5 pues
a lo mejor ya no da si yo este mismo cálculo vale 5281 que hemos hecho antes porque el máximo vale
para para que veáis cuál es el máximo más o menos da igual si es exacto es lo que importa
es lo que importa es la idea entonces lo que tiene que ser vez 5307 es menor que 5200 o dicho
de otra manera 5331 el máximo es mayor que 5200 que quiere decir que el filtro 3 es true si yo
le estuviera pediendo eso para comprar pues me daría que sí y eso me está mediando una expansión
entonces hay algunas que hay filtros que son de expansión y de contracción que son de este tipo
normalmente sumándoles algo al mínimo comparándolo con un multiplicador porque eso es una manera de
ver que el rango es mayor puede hacerse también como vimos comparando la volatilidad directamente
también hay de comparación de apertura y cierre vale de apertura y cierre y también como este
tipo de aquí perdón está de abajo vale que es hay menos lo que es hay menos lo es range es el
rango de la vela sea menor que el rango de la anterior eso que es eso es una insight bar esto
es una insight bar es una manera de llamar un insight bar se entiende no decir que hay menos
low del anterior sea menor que el high menos low del anterior más pequeño es decir un rango
menor se entiende no es eso si lo pintáramos vamos a intentar como tengo un cuadrado es decir
esto sería vale que esta vela el mayor este valor sea menor que este valor máximo mínimo eso que
es es una insight bar entendéis hay muchas veces que las figuras de velas es como se dice pues todos
todos con campo de precio todo es sumando el restando high claw open close todo es lo mismo
como se mide el cuerpo de una vela en el cuerpo de una vela es esto no es el cuerpo open menos
close o close menos open y el rango hay menos menos lo es rango o cuerpo vale y con esas con
esas dos con esos cuatro campos podemos relacionar distintas distintas figuras prácticamente todas
y lo mismo de volatilidad porque muchas de expansión de contracción acordaros que vimos
brevemente en la espera ya me voy acordaros del narrow range vale esto es un narrow range se va
haciendo pequeño narrow range de 3 de 4 acordáis que lo vimos pero no necesariamente alineado
cuidado espera que todo esto es son figuras de precios vale un narrow range es que el rango va
haciéndose menor pero no tiene por qué ser no tiene por qué ser todo el rato alineado
entendéis decir esto es un narrow range de 3 esto es un narrow range de 4 porque el rango cada
vez es más narro más pequeño es esta tiene mayor esta menor esta menor y esa menor es un
narrow range de 4 bueno todo esto al final es comparar el rango se compara simplemente hay menos
lo entendéis como como se relaciona no se analizan los filtros todo esto es así o sea de esto puedes
hacer infinitos bueno infinitos no pero puedes hacer muchos algunos con sentido otros absurdos
otros que son pasarse de frenada hay distintos tipos pero este que os digo pues aquí hay alguno
por ejemplo a mí este no es un poco orgado alberto porque es el cierre o sea no es esta es la
anterior ya del de uno pen uno no sé si es que a lo mejor nos hemos equivocado que alberto pero
el de uno no se sabe las anterior durante la intradía habría que ver cómo va de cero menos
de menos open de cero al final aquí casi todas para mí las que tiene más sentido es usar cero
más que 1 o 2 o cero con unos y pero pero esto de 1 contra 2 para mí rebuscado 1 contra 1 también
la de 5 días aún porque esas muchas que es como los narro de 3 de 2 hay mucha gente que lo usa
porque es una semana con 5 días no es que sea nada es que son es una semana son 5 días es una
unidad es la semana es una unidad en el mercado las pautas estacionales tienen sentido y entonces
es por eso que al final la unidad de 5 días es una unidad de mercado es una semana de mercado
entonces por eso tiene tiene sentido siempre hay que buscar el sentido de esas cosas pero todas
las que son cero comparando con 1 con 2 o con 3 sí pero comparando de 1 con de 1 o de 1 con de 2
para mí está un tantito rebuscadas está por ejemplo 10 está muy bien porque simplemente que
el cierre sea mayor que lópez pero también se podría haber mirado el cierre mayor que el cierre
anterior puedes buscar esta de acuerdo o close mayor es lo mismo pero close mayor que close de
0 que es lo que hemos guardado arriba porque ésta esto es esta vela eso es esta vela son distintas
se entienden a burel y que pregunta burel y alberto pero lo contestas tú esto de close de acordaros
acordaros una cosa que ellos que tengan ese lenguaje porque esto es es importantísimo
importantísimo porque la mejor manera que tenéis a aprender evidentemente es aquí para eso pero que
ver el código ahora habló de decir la función de que los de se puede abrir se puede abrir es
una función de esta que son que son un poco avanzadas podemos decir pero bueno pero no se
pueden abrir y la otra cosa que se puede hacer es pulsar encima f1 y ir a la ayuda de la misma
función y esa es la mejor manera de entender bien lo que se está refiriendo esto es lo más
importante bien seguimos todo claro alberto por ahí alguna cosita seguimos seguimos vamos a abrir
ya el otro que si no nos quedamos bloqueados sigo alberto entonces bueno aquí también está
trabajando un poquito en él y si que había algún filtro que aportaba algo a los cortos sin ser
tampoco super mega todo pero sí que creo que había alguno que era justamente este 11 portaba
algo a los a los cortos a los es el uno es el uno es el uno del original a ver que como antes se
me ha colgado ahora no sé si lo había guardado no lo había guardado o como estaba así metido
bueno es igual vamos al vamos al siguiente no tiene no tiene mayor mayor historia había el había
alguno este ya en sí pues no nos ama del todo y tiene su valor de acuerdo tiene su valor sin
demasiadas complicaciones sin demasiadas complicaciones hay que buscarle recomiendo
buscar una ventana horaria lo que os decía y buscarle algún tipo de salida a mí la salida
en banda contraria ese tipo de estrategias creo que va que va bien y luego hay que buscar alguna
salida para los fallos que cuesta con esto pero se puede buscar también salida y hay versiones que
he visto pues buscando doble salido otra vez en la banda es decir por ejemplo aquí cuando te vuelve
a cerrar otra vez por la banda sales cosas así o también la salida temporal la salida temporal
hay que buscar mejorar los fallos porque es verdad que tiene pocos en el sentido que es buena es
buena entrada pero en general también da bastantes fallos y lo que os digo de las ventanas
horarias suele funcionar también bastante bastante bien bien vamos a ver breve bueno
previamente en lo que nos queda de clase vamos a introducir él está tienes alguna cosita alberto
contestas tu vale aurel y demás los uno hace referencia al día anterior no no entiendes mal
amén pero pero él no lo tiene disponible de acuerdo es decir el por eso os enseñaba el gráfico por
eso nos enseñaba os enseñaba el gráfico hay que entender lo que lo que tienes disponible lo que
no tienes disponible entonces hasta que no acaba el día no tienes disponible el cierre del día
entonces simplemente hay que entender lo que lo que tenemos disponible cada cada momento vale
hablamos también de el de probar la estrategia podemos decir contraria durante la práctica lo
vimos y perdón durante durante la teoría lo vimos aquí lo tengo se lo tengo todo en
multicharse así que vamos a rezar vamos a rezar a que multicharse nos tenga la amabilidad de
funcionar venga para que al hacer esto me he fumado la pantalla ahora venga vamos con ello
a ver si hay suerte voy a empezar por el daily y lo voy a abrir en entraría a ver si empezamos
por lo fácil iba iba bien que hace haber raciones de fiction os lo comenté y es un
sistema que fue muy famoso durante muchos muchos años pueden haber variaciones pueden haber
distintas distintos conceptos del mismo tema al final es un concepto básico es es justo el
contrario justo el contrario de del que hemos visto ahora de mil reversos es decir si antes
lo que hacíamos era comprar cuando estábamos por debajo de la mente inferior aquí lo que vamos
a hacer es vender cuando aprendemos la banda inferior y comprar cuando lo hacemos por la
banda superior es un sistema duro decir muy tendencial es el súper extremo de las más
tendenciales que hay porque llegamos que lleva al extremo aquello de que tendenciales compras
caro para vender más caros decir o vendes caro para luego recomprar más caro en este caso es
muy llevado al extremo vale muy llevado al extremo y pues porque normalmente cuando compras o vendes
tiene siempre la sensación que lo haces como tarde que lo haces como tarde en sí el código es sencillo
pero como todos pues puede tener distintas distintas variantes tampoco en este le hemos
dado muchas vueltas vale no le hemos dado muchas vueltas pero yo os explico las vueltas que se le
puede dar porque a partir de ahí pues podéis explorar hacerlo no hay hay vueltas para la
entrada para retrasar la entrada por ejemplo pedirle dos cierres en vez de un cierre pedirle
que sí pues lo que os digo que es que sea dos cierres por encima pedirle alguna figura de velas
determinada que además esté que además del cierre por encima de la banda para evitar algunas
señales un poco tontas pues que además cierre por encima del máximo del día anterior que casi
siempre es así pero puede haber algún caso que no casi siempre se va a dar pero vais a ver
algún caso a ver si encuentro alguna hora en que haya caído así tonto y no lo espero primero que
tenga la misma banda puesta que en el gráfico tengo la banda 47 que entiendo que aquí le hemos
dado un poquito al optimizador normalmente normalmente siempre va a ser así para pintar
también las líneas más gruesas porque si no creo que no las van a ver del todo del todo bien a mí
es una entrada que me gusta mucho pero por ejemplo el todo no le gusta nada es decir esto
yo es que tengo una mentalidad tremendamente tendencial y me gusta pero es verdad que un
sistema muy duro muy duro y muy difícil muy difícil lo sabe puede pasar épocas muy largas
contra dos fuertes y sólo apto para activos muy tendenciales entonces a ver si encuentro alguna
no es habitual ya os digo normalmente cuando va a romper la banda va a ver cerrado pero puede
haber algún caso puede haber algún caso en que no puede haber algún caso otra otro filtro
también que hay versiones que he visto de haber ratio mira este aquí se me da por eso lo explico
ahora es entonces una vez pasa eso poner un stop de compra en el máximo de esta vela en
vez de comprar al mercado vale porque entonces le pides que siga el impulso entendéis es decir
en vez de pedirle comprar al mercado le pido le pongo un stop de compra aquí por ejemplo aquí
no hubiera entrado aquí no hubiera entrado porque porque le estoy pidiendo que siga con impulso
porque es verdad que hay muchas veces que eso es lo que hace el anti tendencial que justo va a la
banda y vuelve no como pasa aquí ver vez no cierra como pasa aquí no es entonces para evitar
esas entradas se puede poner ese filtro añadido pero le ven hay activos que no acaba de ir bien
porque acaba entrando igual y entra más más caro entonces todo tiene un precio y todo tiene un
precio normalmente un activo que tú estés viendo como este que optimizando te pone una banda de 47
quiere decir que quiere frenarte un poco porque es muy volátil necesita oscilar más sin que eso
supongan entradas puede ser que te vaya bien algún filtro de este tipo no es retrasar un poco la
entrada retrasar un poco la entrada para evitar algunas entradas en falso pero claro el precio
ese tipo de sistemas es este ves pillar estos trades tan magníficos de acuerdo es decir es lo
que pasa luego cuando el activo pues se pega a una host increíble o pega tírones fuertes pues se
queda adentro y lo mismo para la salida la salida más convencional y más conservadora es en el
mínimo aquí nuevamente tenemos implementar una versión que es un poco extraña vale es un poco
porque realmente bueno hay dos hay con la media puede salir directamente a esto con la media
central o pedirle un cierre por debajo de acuerdo y hay versiones que usan doble vale que es un poco
un poco esto vale es un poco esto es decir como un como un esto de seguridad lo que pasa que aquí
está un poco al revés eso es un poco extraño no sé la verdad me acuerdo porque lo pusimos así
igual estamos haciendo pruebas o lo que sea pero poner cierre de stop en la banda vale y que no
deja de ser un stop de seguridad vale vamos a hacer esa prueba rápida aquí ahora a ver si nos
en este caso nos mejora o nos empeora lo normal es que nos empeore porque está está optimizado
lo normal es que nos empeore aquí tenemos un profeta de 255 vale lo normal es que empeore pero
dejarme probaros lo que voy a hacer ahora para que aquí la versión lo que hace es cerrar cerrar
cuando en stop en la media de acuerdo cierra en stop en la media lo que vamos a hacer es pedirle
que cierre acuerdo que cierre por debajo por encima de la media y le vamos a dejar de stop la banda
contraria por si hay un latigazo fuerte sin cerrar que tenga esa seguridad de esa seguridad
de salirse de acuerdo no quedarse ahí enganchado vale es decir vamos a invertir un poco
un poco el mecanismo no es que invertir es que ahora tiene los dos pero no actúa el segundo
porque ahora lo que hace es cerrar ahora lo que hace es cerrar si en stop en la banda central vale
entonces yo ahora le voy a pedir que cierre le voy a pedir que cierre por ejemplo aquí no saldría
saldría dos velas después vale y probablemente peor en este caso es decir ahora a veces muchas
veces saldrá peor otra saldrá mejor hay que hay que verlo a mí me gusta un poco más así me gusta
un poco más a ver el mar que posiciono igual a uno de begin sell next bar ad don't stop stop
vale y aquí le digo if close menor que average a ver no a ver esto si simplemente estoy invirtiendo
esta estas dos variables para que lo veáis aquí le hago el a van y aquí le hago la me imagino que
así con esa configuración pero ahora si mejor ahora sería la hostia porque aquí ahora le he pedido
que cubra si le pongo un estocto siempre que esté que se cortó pero vale cuando cierre por encima
de la media entonces le cierre mercado en la siguiente ahora recalculará supongo bueno tengo
metido este aquí no tengo metido otros de aquí leyendo la curso de ratio no es el que tengo metido
bueno lógicamente como suponíamos ha empeorado como suponíamos ha empeorado a ver porque me
acuerdo la imagen antes como suponíamos no puedo enseñar las dos pero bueno ya os digo que
profit factor y demás general empeora si empiezo a los dos lados pero los dos lados pero los dos
lados era un simple para que vieras la diferencia para que veras la diferencia aquí ahora le
estamos pidiendo que cierre por encima para poder saber hasta que no cierran por encima no sale
no lo hacen esto aquí antes lo había hecho aquí ahora pues lo hace un poquito después y más a mí
me gusta un poco más así pero no quiere decir que ahora no vaya mejor porque repito este está el
canal optimizado y es totalmente normal con un canal optimizado lo normal es que es que vaya
es que vaya peor pero habría que ver si ahora probando otro canal pues mejor o va peor o sea
no necesita tener un canal de esa forma simplemente son distintas opciones o distintas maneras de
el mismo concepto de acuerdo del mismo concepto el tema de filtros
o tema de salidas vale vamos a ir filtros más salidas vale en salidas sí que no hay mi opinión
muchas cosas que hacer con un tendencial no hay muchas cosas que hacer con un tendencial si
queremos un tendencial puro un tendencial puro para que voy a volver a la configuración anterior
quiero la que está optimizada simplemente para que lo veáis porque nos lo he llegado ni enseñar
y enseñar a estamos superados si vienes y cambia un tren veréis que cambia algún
algún pequeño tray ha cambiado no a porque no ha compilado venga tira ahora ahora ahora si
no es la persona se pone ya se me sacó la otra vez esto tío no te creo no te puedo creer no
me carga abierto ahora no se queda como debajo no ahora ahora se queda como debajo vale vale
es parecido es parecido a lo anterior largos cortos realmente en este caso va un poco mejor
de cortos que de largos por razones obvias definitiva es lo que os digo que tenemos aquí
tenemos un sistema con un porcentaje de aciertos muy bajo todo lo contrario otra vez todo lo
contrario del caso anterior vale que lo estamos viendo ahora en multichars aquí tenemos un
porcentaje de aciertos y ahora cuando lo encuentre os lo os lo digo cuando lo encuentre
58 por ciento nunca me acuerdo cambio de programa y nunca me acuerdo donde saca la
cosa de verdad es un drama esto aquí aquí tenemos los datos que buscábamos vale aquí tenemos un
45 9 tampoco es muy muy bajo pero es más bajo y fijaros que para que voy a hacerlo más pequeño
voy a poner el tiempo para que lo quite está fijaros que tenemos un una veras winning de
2 millones y un de situación realmente muy superior el álvaro h winning tanto en el largo
como en el corto aunque esto habría que verlo porcentaje pero bueno ya no se ve aquí aquí
podemos ver el análisis un poco mejor este que veíamos antes en entre excesión de los runups y
de los y demás es que aquí es 63 por ciento por daros que el petróleo llegó a ser negativo por
ser magnitudes muy bestias de un menos 8 y el average valúa 8 por ciento con 2 por ciento aquí
tenemos que los largos corren mucho más es la diferencia aquí los largos los positivos
los positivos corren muchísimo más que antes es justo lo contrario lo contrario que teníamos
antes lo contrario que teníamos antes y de esta forma se invierte se invierte totalmente la
tortilla con el caso anterior y aquí por lo tanto es lo que os digo aquí hay que vigilar por no
cortar es complicado por eso es complicado gestionar las salidas de un tendencial porque
necesita dejar correr donde sí que se puede mejorar un tendencial es filtrando entradas
lógicamente filtrando entradas aumentando las probabilidades se puede filtrar entradas pero se
debe filtrar entradas en muchos casos pero en las salidas no recomiendo marear mucho la pérdida
de acuerdo no os recomiendo marear mucho la pérdida al final hay que salir por un estilo
traily esto no deja de ser un traily la media móvil pero podéis buscar otra podéis buscar
pero tiene que ser una salida que le deje volver tiene que ser una salida que le deje volver hecho
a lo mejor esta es demasiado justa es tiene que ser una salida que le deje volver puede ser un
trailing puede ser la misma media por simplificación y no añadir grados de libertad pero no es
conveniente ya os digo darle darle muchas vueltas porque es necesario es necesario dejarle que
desarrolle los straights para un tendencial sino ya no va a ser un tendencial si quieres otra cosa
pues puedes perfectamente entonces convertirlo en un breakout de acuerdo y entonces ya sí que tiene
sentido tp tiene sentido protegerlo etcétera vale pero en un tendencial en mi opinión no hay que
usar nunca objetivo vale y hay que poner un una salida tipo trailing que le permita al mercado
volver y que nos garantice con todas las comillas del mundo de que la tendencia se ha acabado no
es lo que buscamos nosotros lógicamente no nos vamos a conseguir en todas las ocasiones pero la
mayoría de personas hay que intentar conseguir eso qué problema tienen esos sistemas que este
mismo tipo de salida le va a hacer sufrir mucho cuando no hay una tendencia y ahí está el problema
de haber rato de acuerdo y ahí está ahí está entonces qué más podemos hacer bueno vamos aquí
este tipo de sistemas trabajados se puede trabajar también interdiariamente o se puede trabajar en
la versión original de hace muchísimos años que la creó él lo operaba en horizontes de
diario incluso se comenta que podían ser asa semanal pero bueno y lo hacía en una cesta de
commodities bastante grande es decir al final este tipo de sistemas la única manera de trabajarlos
es agrupándolos en otros hemos intentado evaluar o mirar un poco algo algo parecido algo parecido
lo hemos hecho aquí en el porfolio trader vamos a ver si tal porque eso también nos ha dado unos
cuantos problemillas antes bueno tenemos uno aquí con algunos activos seleccionados eso no me acuerdo
como estaba de gestión de gestión monetaria ya estamos y esto es un poco la manera de trabajar
este tipo de estrategias de acuerdo de trabajar este tipo de estrategias que tienen su buen
momento pero tienen su mal entonces al final en un porfolio tendencial puede tener su cabida pero
necesita como como ya hemos hablado siempre de tener otro tipo de sistemas en el porfolio que
compense en estos pésimos momentos que va a tener ahora es lo que os digo son sistemas y cuando hay
tendencia cuando pasan cosas ya veis que van pasando no del petróleo del oro cosas de pronto
increíbles de subidas de caídas o el cacao ahora recientemente no pues ahí están de acuerdo ahí
ahí están no sé si teníamos el cacao aquí metido alberto sal que acabó quiero unos gana
otros pierde ahí está un poco la dificultad averigual en la otra estaba la guarda de c es no
es ese pues en cc no ha ido muy bien del todo en cc no ha ido muy bien del todo pero hasta en la
verdad entre sí yo no tengo esto contado no es que el cacao justamente se había pegado un sopapo
bastante considerable ya no quería mirarlo roba cc no vale porque está está pasa lo del instrumento
abierto no sé por qué no coge la no lo coge no entiendo la verdad no entiendo porque al final lo
coge de tres station y no debería de venir con el dólar pero no sé por qué no sé por qué dar a
error el a divisa que le coge y es verdad está sin está sin sin divisa no sé por qué no se lo da
a tres de eso la verdad es que voy a hacer se lo voy a borrar se lo voy a volver a añadir a volver
a añadir y listos la pantalla bugeada está está había bugeado también el emisor este estaba
estaba ya que haciendo cosas y no y no salía vamos a intentar añadir ahora añadiendo lo
directamente me lo me lo coge a simbol sólo está en el hice además no sé si no se analice no digo
que ahora se lo ha añadido eso que me ha cogido el nombre igual ahora al volverse lo a añadir me lo
me coge ahora la divisa eso es es y hasta que eso eso es raro lo tiene que dar no sé por qué no se
lo daba ese dato ya no sé si se va porque está parado a por no sé por qué no sé lo de verdad es
que no entiendo por qué no lo coge la divisa de ahora ya sé ahora sí que ya parece que lo debe
haber cogido bien bueno me rindo me rindo ya está no pero es que es que del hice no tenemos historia
ahora estaba la la hostia del cacao es la hostia del cacao como no se ve nada ahí está colgado otra
vez has visto la hostia que se ha pegado el cacao sí sí pero no sé por qué no coge él no coge
no coge él dice ese y no me traga tío manera aunque ya le he puesto dólar pero pero ni así
la postura ya que está declarado también aquí no aquí y esto usa y se tanza aquí está joder
ahora sí no sé por qué no tenía la divisa post ahora sí ahora sí ahora sí ahora sí ahora sí
ahora sí es que quería ver por qué daba tantas pérdidas porque me da realmente con tanta subida
vale a la pilla pero para los que está adaptado al petróleo no esté ahora sí tema de complicado
pero es que ves ha pasado mucho tiempo lateral y claro pues hay sufriendo no hay sufriendo
habría que haberle filtrado algo y este se lo voy a quitar de momento las comisiones porque ahora
mismo no tengo la idea super laterales en fin es el que veis ejemplificado lo bueno y malo de
este tipo de estrategias sufren lo que nos ha escrito los laterales porque de manera tiene
un montón de señales falsas y lo que decía y hay que buscar la manera y buscar algún filtro
para que para retrasar las entradas en algunos casos porque cuando coja tendencia pues ya da
igual que entre más caro no pero porque si no los laterales lo cosen aún así por eso os digo que
la bolsa es muy complicado ese tipo de sistemas pero en commodities suele ir bien pero necesita
filtros necesita buscar filtros de tendencia que son de este tipo de ese tipo que habéis visto o
simplemente añadir algún otro algún otro filtro de tendencia como puede ser otra media o tipo
de x como habéis visto de este tipo de este tipo una de x puede valer y también de figuras
como os decía también hay versiones intradiarias como puede ser esta que vais a ver ahora
sabiendo esto no venga a ver si nos carga si nos cargan si estaba silenciado perdón perdón
perdón aquí hablando hablando solo para no renegar como se llama renegar en castellano
como se reniega en castellano
también que me dice como es renegar regri re guiñar
las femar y jose te has tirado un triple pero del otro campo lo menos dos campos fuera
un triple desde la grada más o menos
blasfemar no blasfemar a renegar es en castellano no matame matame renegar es en castellano
acuño es verdad es verdad calla calla calla ahora estaba haciendo un castellanismo si si
entonces lo que decía lo que decía jose es que en catalán se dice re llená que joder
yo mi catalán es lamentable o sea yo tengo yo cuando yo cuando hacía exámenes en la universidad
me lo dejaban hacer en castellano en castellano porque catalán hacía un montón de faltas y
claro se hacía no sé cuántas faltas se despenían y era es que de verdad siempre me ha costado mucho
escribir solo hablo bien pero hago muchas más faltas en catalán castellano ortografía pero
los pronunciables eso que lo inventó de verdad que los castellanos los castellanos
no sabéis de que os hablo pero los que estéis hay catalanes ya sabéis ya sabéis de que os
hablo ya con los pronunciables de a ver cómo como era lo de lo de renegar en catalán como es que
no tengo por ser seguro que es igual es renajá es renajá pues sí sí sí es igual es igual renajá
buidar el pub de xana desbutar desbravarse a desfugarse de una paz enjegar a esbravarse
a escalfar a escupir joder la madre mía la de sinónimos que hay todo esto mientras el
multicharge mientras el multicharge acaba de de backfilear el el archivo a ver cómo se dice
backfilear en castellano como se dice backfiling venga seguimos con la clase de idiomas porque de
otra cosa no podemos vale porque como hoy la tecnología nos está matando pues vamos a hacer
clase idiomas venga backfiling rellenar rellenando rellenarnos y pues pues a ver si acaba ya de
rellenar en el el amigo venga rellenando no no es igual parece que es igual es renajar igual
sí sí pues yo pensaba que no pensaba que era de frente no sé por qué pensaba que renegar
era catalán y castellano se decía distinto pero este no lo había abierto antes yo ya alberto así
se me ha roto entonces entonces no no no ha cachado los datos si está está está bien está muy está
muy bien bueno pues nada oye es igual era lo mismo pero ni tradí mal era lo mismo pero en
entraría era lo mismo pero en entraría aquí el bueno de alberto simplemente hemos hecho una
versión entraría planteándolo como como habíamos hecho anteriormente con unos filtros ya está con
horario y tal poco para que veáis el esquema básico sin más el esquema básico este es un
poco el esquema entre a diario siempre va un poco así siempre va un poco así filtros horarios filtros
de largos y o de cortos que pueden ser el mismo o no vale es decir en ambos casos en tiempo y en
filtro puede ser o no puede ser es las dos las dos cosas hay que considerarlas está aquí
tiene mucho sentido filtrado separado aquí empieza a tener menos es lo que os decía de acuerdo
podemos evaluarlo podemos hacer una evaluación preliminar mirarlo de acuerdo pero aquí empieza
a gustarme menos vale en bolsa es muy claro a la que ya vamos a ir a commodities es más duro
y puede ser que utilicemos el mismo filtro con lo cual ya el mismo filtro quiere decir que
lógicamente si es de tendencia pues será el cista por encima imaginaos una media y bajista
por debajo porque no es el que no usaremos uno distinto para largos que para cortos si es de
volatilidad pues lo mismo si hay volatilidad para operar bien o sea puedo negar el filtro pero
que las reglas es el mismo puede ser que lo lógico es que sea la contraria en algunos casos no en
algunos tipos de filtro volatilidad o expansión es la misma regla para largo para corto pero
lógicamente si es por encima de una media no será igual no será lo contrario pero no es otra media
o tal y lo mismo para el tema de filtros horarios ahora es lo mismo para el tema de filtros no no
quiere decir que sea obligatorio usarlo es decir que es una opción que entraría tiene mucho sentido
evaluar y que normalmente en entraría la evaluamos normalmente luego puede descartarse dice oye pues
no voy toda la sesión perfecto pero que tiene sentido evaluarlo se entiende no es más complicado
el valenciano catalán coseno no he estudiado parecidos no de gramática y esto no la verdad
que nunca he tenido ocasión de leer es que jose comenta que valenciano es peor aún no he
tenido ocasión de estudiarlo ni de leer nada en profundidad respecto pero pensaba que a nivel
de idioma de estructura lengua y demás eran muy parecidos dice el que en valencia no digan que
ya ha cargado los narices bueno pues lo que os digo el código es este como ya habéis visto
mismo historia que es un monetario igual simplemente añadimos la regla de los filtros
que no sé si alberto ha hecho los mismos o no ha hecho los mismos vale ha hecho los mismos y
ya está sin más vale si más para la clase siguiente evaluaremos un poquito era la idea
claro la idea es verla a que no era la idea que no que vale vale no no pasa nada que no
tiempo de trabajar lo más bueno esta semana de más y un poquito más complicada por los días
festivos que ya el viernes viene viene también a trabajar y ayer también pero lógicamente pues
las mismas horas y encima mañana también tenemos un poquito más complicado entonces aquí sí que
queríamos mirar unos filtros específicos y no nos llegaba pero pero como os decía trabajaremos
todo esto los selectores la semana que viene sobre todo para las salidas pero intentaremos
al menos estos estos de bollinger pues darles un una capita pintura para acabar de dejarlos más
más limpios y más aprovechables entonces seguramente en estos dos al menos también
veremos los filtros para la semana que viene trabajaremos más los los que espero el concepto
repito que es el mismo acuerdo el concepto es el mismo trabajar filtros que sí que pueden
ser unos más para tendenciales que para mi reversión es verdad pero en algunos casos son similares y que
y que se basan sobre todo en pautas de precios pero sí que hay algunos que son más de tendencia y
otros que son más de no tendencia eso eso es así porque al final bueno la tendencia nuevamente
no deja de ser una expansión vale y la y la anti tendencia normalmente es una contracción
entonces eso ya te marca te marca una situación inversa a veces es el mismo filtro pero al revés
de acuerdos decir ya ya os explique aquello de que las expansiones a veces son contraintuitivos
porque lo que anticipa una expansión es una contracción y lo que anticipa una contracción es
una expansión entonces los mejores entradas de los anti tendenciales se dan post expansión y al
revés y el revés no hoy está el cacao no donde tenía la expansión después de un tiempo de
contracción entonces hay veces que es el mismo frito pero invertido entonces esto suele darse
pero bueno sí que sí que algunos aunque ya hemos visto bastantes pero sí que antes de final de
curso trataremos de crearos un poco una una lista un poco más más útil de algunos filtros
especialmente útiles vale y esto me comprometo me comprometo a daros lo antes de antes de acabar
antes de que probablemente la última probablemente la última clase donde hagamos el repaso y tal pues
el repaso y recopilación de todo y reuniremos ya lo mejor de lo que tengamos pues seguramente
la última clase creo que es el día de darlo esto ya dar las las perlas no alberto las perlas hay
que dar las el último el último día el último día me las guardo para el último día las perlas
el santo curial todos todos están aquí por eso lo sabes pues no sé alberto si dejarlo
porque estar aquí viendo cargar el gráfico para estar aquí viendo cargar el gráfico a casi que
dejamos que se vayan a cenar los otros también y el martes que será otro día porque esto de
verdad que es bastante frustrante porque normalmente hemos dicho no tal tanto cargar no sé qué está
pasando yo creo que que hay algún baque en alguno de los dos que está limitando la carga o algo
porque no entiendo no entiendo porque tala tanto y no tiene de tarda no sé no no pasa
algo raro ya sé que pasa algo raro pero no sé decirte que entonces la conexión me marca bien
la verdad y sates a pero bueno la vuelvo a quitar la cámara vamos a quitar otra vez son iguales
para ver si romo una vale pues igual le cambié la fecha ya está a coño y no había llenado en
seguir antes años solo va esto no va a ser no puede ser como que no se me oye pues estoy
pinchado no me habéis no se oye a ver pues habrá colgado algo todo esto no se oye preguntaba en
escrita ver hola hola hola hola ahora no me ven encima y ahora no no me oyen pues ha muerto
pues sí que vamos ya de puta madre hola hola hola hola pues ha muerto por ser pinchado a ver
para la pantalla a ver hola hola ahora sí hay que joderse pues se está hablando estaba estaba para
la pantalla a ver a ver si de compartir a ver si efectivamente esto esto es que está hoy flamenco
no sé por qué no se me oía chicos no sé por qué no se me oía pero no se me oía hoy estamos en una
rebelión de las máquinas en toda regla o sea pero vaya de las de las buenas estamos en una rebelión
de las buenas y esto va a feeling me queda la que va a feeling le voy a cargar le voy a cambiar la
fecha por porque así lo obligas a recargar a ver la voy a poner aquí si le voy a meter 500
atrás ahí está ya pero bueno al menos así ha parado no a ver ahora harle pido la grande
pero como vuelve no mantiene lo que tenía ya tío parece que no esté cacheando espérate a ver si
está el cut man haces en caché tío sin disco a ver si me está quedando sin disco no creo a ver si
está desconectado el caché v3 station está en guardar el local tío está guardando el local
pero no sé tío haya aquella opción pero pero no sé el edge no al cromises pero se lo tengo
cerrado como lo sabes como lo sabes nada tira tira jaimito tira tira no sé tío no sé esto
antes lo tenía pero parecía warnen de coletos para terminal parts can't differ from the story
que al vez no no es que esto no sé tío no sé no sé qué fe no sé qué a familia vamos a irnos
tío vamos a irnos porque es que esto yo ya no sé qué tocar no sé qué tocar pero esto hoy está
especialmente lento y además no debería estar todo cachado es que ahora si encima no se me está
viendo la pantalla ahora alberto a pues avísame tú también jaimito o sea ya si encima no se me
viene la pantalla ya es que bueno y familia lo dejamos lo dejamos porque esto es absurdo desde
cualquier punto de vista entonces la semana que viene lo acabamos tenemos tenemos pensado hacer
el tema de trabajar salidas con las estrategias que ya hemos hecho hasta ahora el tipo tipo que
ya los traemos hechos explicaremos realmente las salidas pero pero luego ya las aplicaremos
traemos algunos aplicados y tenemos aplicar aplicar algunos indirectos también para que veáis cómo se
hace y y veremos también si si nos da tiempo que creo que sí intentaremos aplicar filtros a este
y a los dos de bolingan vale para justo con las salidas y los filtros dejar estos dos ya redondos
para para que podáis darle algún tipo de uso hay que tener claro que son sistemas sencillos
aplicables bastante a bastantes cerrados de mercado es decir no son todo terreno de acuerdo son
sistemas todo terreno y hay sistemas poco más cerrados estos son sistemas cerrados es decir
muy específicos de activos que tienen una valga me el juego de palabras tienen tendencias ser
tendenciales o tendencia no serlo entonces pero bueno ese tipo de sistemas también son útiles y
también van bien en esos activos ya digo las materias primas generalmente suelen ir bastante
bien pero hay que mejorarlo como está si es demasiado duro demasiado duro hay que mejorarle
un poco las entradas al tendencial sobre todo vale así que nada familia siento mucho la clase
hoy tan la cámara porque tal no sirve para nada que no la que no la tenga así que al menos pues
me ven cabreado y esto vale nos vemos el martes que viene recordar aquellos que queráis que no
pues que no que mañana estaré por robot trader me parece que es a las 6 no sé cuánto tanto estaré
pues tengo que tengo una ponencia de hora y media para y luego las preguntas no creo que
una hora o dos lo que no que no sé la ponencia tampoco hay hay límite ahí vale y que justamente
voy a hablar de salidas la mayoría de cosas sabéis pues ya os las he comentado pero bueno pues ahí
comentar un poquito algo de salidas y a raíz de esta ponencia la completaremos para la clase del
martes digamos que mañana iniciaremos esta parte de salidas que no quiero ver pero que lógicamente
el martes que viene haremos la clase nosotros de salidas y más profundamente que en el robot
el robot el enseñó cosas hechas no las hago y de acuerdo así que dónde podéis verlo os lo pongo
en el disc or el rico os lo pongo en el disco porque ahora mismo no tengo el enlace a mano
no tengo el enlace a mano y mañana os lo pongo en el disco mañana os lo pongo en el disco para
para que lo podáis lo podáis ver en directo de acuerdo aquí lo que quiera así que nada más por
hoy os veo el martes que viene hasta pronto a esperar espera espera espera que la cara toda que
siempre queda más chachi para acabar si vaya a decir la clase no sé si la dejaremos grabada
entera igual la cortamos esta porque hemos enseñado y mucha mucha pantalla vacía buenas noches hasta
el martes chao